This number… is illegal.
Well kinda.
I switched out a few digits to protect myself,
since, you know, it’s illegal, but just
the possession of this number is enough to
get you arrested in the US.
To understand why, we need to learn some cryptology.
Prime numbers are numbers that can only be
divided by themselves and one.
For example, nothing multiplies together to
get seven other than seven and one, nothing
multiplies together to get 29 other than 29
and one, this will be the same for all primes.
It’s not that hard to check if a smaller
number is prime.
For seven you just check if seven divided
by one is a whole number, seven divided by
two, by three, by four, by five, by six, nothing
other than seven can divide seven into a whole
number.
As you get to bigger and bigger numbers you
have to check more and more times to determine
if a number is prime.
For 43,721, you’d have to perform 21,861
calculations to check if its prime.
As it turns out, it is.
That means that its exceedingly difficult
to find new primes.
The largest prime that we know of right now
is 274,207,281-1.
There is an infinite number of primes since
there is an infinite number of numbers, but
it just takes an enormous amount of computing
power to find these primes.
So what’s the point of finding primes?
Well they’re actually quite useful for encryption.
For the sake of simplicity, let’s take two
small primes, 11 and 13.
If we were actually encrypting data, we would
be using primes with thousands of digits,
but that would probably make this explanation
a little complicated.
Now multiply 11 and 13 together in your head.
You can probably figure out pretty easily
that together they make 143.
Now how long would it take you to work backwards
and figure out what multiplies together to
get 143?
Probably a pretty long time.
It’s the same with computers.
It’s very easy for them to multiply two
numbers together and find out what the product
is, but its very hard for them to take the
product and find out what the factors are.
When you’re logging on to, say, your bank
account online, your computer will send the
number 143, which is known as the public key,
to the bank’s server.
The bank will then check if 11 and 13, the
private keys, multiply to 143 and if so, it
will let you in.
Everyone has the public key, but only the
bank has the private keys.
If you wanted the find the private keys, you
would need a computer to factor the public
key, which would take thousands of years because,
once again, in the real world, the keys aren’t
11 and 13, they’re prime numbers with thousands
upon thousands of digits.
With the amount of money it would take to
set up a computer system that could actually
factor the primes, it’s just not worth it.
The bigger the prime number, the longer it
would take to factor, and the more secure
it is.
That’s why organizations like the Electronic
Frontier Foundation are willing to pay up
to $250,000 for new prime numbers.
Alright, that’s all the math we’re going
to do today, I promise.
Back to our illegal number.
In 1998, The Digital Millennium Copyright
Act was passed in the US, making it illegal
to circumvent copyright measures and to produce
or distribute tools that can be used to get
around copyright protection systems.
Our illegal number, 8565078 and so on and
so forth, is a prime number that is the source
code used to decrypt the copyright protection
of DVD’s.
The copyright protection was used to stop
people from downloading or duplicating movies
on their computers and, with this number,
the protection was rendered useless.
Programs were created that allowed individuals
to make bootleg copies of movies all because
of this number.
All the while, individuals were breaking the
law not only by copying DVD's, but also just
by being in possession of this number, an
easily findable prime.
I hope you enjoyed this week’s episode.
Last week I covered Big Mac economics which
you can find here.
If you enjoy these videos, make sure to click
subscribe here.
Also, please follow me on Twitter @WendoverPro.
Thanks, for watching, and I’ll be back next
week with a special video not from That Wikipedia
List.